wir müssen gemeinsam noch auf folgende
bilderschauen einer mord und zwar in
direkten umfeld von der vladimir putin
in moskau ging eine autobombe hoch sehen
wir hier und darin saß eine sehr
bekannte frau ihr name daher dubina sie
ist die tochter von einem der ganz
großen propagandisten in russland man
fragte sich in der nacht wer war das wer
hat das gemacht die ukraine bereits frau
gesagt wir waren das nicht und jetzt
auch das schauen wir an gibt's ein
kenner video und zwar von ihm ja und
dieser mann ein oppositioneller der
bekennt sich eben dazu sagt er seine
widerstandsgruppe eine partisan gruppe
stecke dahinter und man habe noch ganz
andere ziele man wolle nämlich putin
beseitigen töten wie ernst ist das
zunehmen wie ernst ist diese partie
sahen diese bisher unbekannte
widerstandsgruppe zu nehmen
das wird hier viel diskutiert das größte
thema könnte man sagen und auch die
hoffnung ein bisschen gibt es womöglich
wirklich ein widerstand der dort in
russland organisiert wird die quelle
dieses videos ist ein ehemaliger kreml
abgeordneter sozusagen ein
oppositioneller der aus moskau hier nach
kiew geflogen ist der hat das bekannt
gemacht auf welchen informationen dass
fuß und wie
seriös diese tatsächlich sind das wird
sich jetzt herausstellen es gibt bislang
noch keine ukrainischen offiziellen der
sich dazu geäußert hat geäußert hat man
sich zu dem vorwurf der russin das ist
die ukraine war so dass die ukraine die
tochter oder der geheimdienst die
tochter von juden umgebracht habe das so
zielinski berater auch mir gegenüber sei
falsch dass da keine ukrainische aktion
gewesen von daher wird man jetzt schauen
müssen vor allem auch wie die russische
propaganda darauf reagiert denn in
russland hat man ja bereits wenige
minuten nachdem das ganze passiert ist
gesagt das sei die ukraine gewesen
gestern abend nach zerbst der autokorsos
mit russischen flaggen und auch mit dem
z also im zeichen des krieges was auch
auf diesen vielen panzern hier war
hinter mir von daher wird man jetzt
schauen müssen vor allem wie der kreml
auf diese vorwürfe reagiert
auch sma vielen herzlichen dank mit den
neuesten informationen aus der ukraine
zu einem mord auch im ganz nahen umfeld
von der putin danke der nach kiew
[Musik]